I used to get a
bicycle and by get a bicycle that's
means steal one out of somebody's yard
and sometime it could be anybody's
bicycle i' take that sucker and I bike
over to my girl's house I had this
little you know beautiful little white
girl I was seeing and she was you know
that you know that rubenesque little bad
girl you know and we go over there and I
sneak up in her room and they had a cat
they had this gray cat I had to sneak
past this little [__] bro and he
was was always trying to start something
with me you know like he like we had met
in a previous life and I'd done
something wrong to him you know like
maybe like a couple hundred years ago
he'd been you know was eating a piece of
fish or something by a river and I came
up and stole that carp out of his hand
and so you know now he's out here he's
trying to get back at me so whenever I
go into this girl's house I sneaking
through the laundry room they had a door
to the outside you go into the laundry
room and come into the kitchen well that
cat this little gray hitter he he would
hide in there they had all these towels
and you know dryer sheets and stacks of
all kind of stuff or whatever in the
laundry room so and it was Pitch Black
and I couldn't cut the light on because
you were worried you know you don't want
light going out under the door into the
kitchen what if the mom's walking down
the hall or whatever you know I couldn't
have the family see that I was sneaking
in so I'd get in that laundry room and
dude it was like the laundry room was
like about nine or t feet long to that
from one door to the next door and it
was just a gauntlet bro and every time
like clockwork that little gray
[__] come flying off on one of
the top ropes like Jimmy Superfly
snooker and just do that four-leg drop
on me
just I mean just and then it was on boy
it was on and you couldn't even see us
it was just this
dark Fiasco
and then you know I'd make it up to her
room and then and then the cool thing
was so then I'd get into the kitchen
finally get away from that little M you
know that little deal and I then I have
to sneak up to her
room um and the stairs went over her
parents bedroom so you had to
like real stuff step on the sides of the
stairs that was a trick don't step out
in the middle of the [__] stairs like
somebody that never broken anybody's
house before step on the side of them
steps you know so it's really the where
the wood is strong and so it doesn't
make any sound you get up to the top and
then go sneaking old girl's bed hope you
enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this
one